اكيد راح نبردلش حلقتنا اليوم بالحفله
الاسطوري اللي صار امبارح في ملعب مرسول
بارد بالرياض لتقديم نادي النصر للاعب
ولجديد البرتغال العالم كرستيانو رونالدو
لشغل الدنيا والعالم من ايام وبالفعل مثل
ما كان متوقع الحفل كان اسطوري والحضور
تجاوزكليتين الف شخص الحماس كان كبير
والفرح كان العنوان العريض للمناسبه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا قبل الحفل كان في مؤتمر
صحفي لرونالدو تحدث خلاله عن حماس والخوض
هالتجربه وانه ليس من السهل الفوز باي
مباراه في الوقت الحالي لان الفرق باتت
اكثر استعدادا وكره القدم كانت صارت
مختلفه وانه غير مهتم لاي كلام يقال عن
انضمامه الى النادي اما لحظه دخول الدون
الى الملعب وهو مرتديلا لقميص نادي النصر
لاول مره كانت تاريخيه ولا تخلو من الطاقه
الايجابيه اللي كانت كفيله في اضافه
التفاؤل والحماس والمحبه اللي كانت عنوان
الحفله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
التفاؤل والمحبه والالف من التواصلوا
لحضور حفل تقديم الدون كنج من نجوم العالم
يتصدرت العناوين لكثير من الصحف العربيه
لكن مصطلح الجنون الرياضي وعباره الحفاوه
والجماهيريه طهوا على عناوين الصحف
الاجنبيه التي يبدو انها تفاعلت مع الحفل
الكبير والجماهيريه الكبيره التي حظي بها
النجم كره القدم البرتغالي في السعوديه
وهو مرتدي قميص نادي ناديه الجديد خلينا
نشوف بعض العناوين للسيطره على الصحف
الاجنبيه
ومن بين الفيديوهات اللي انتشرت بشكل كبير
عن الحفل وحصل على ما يقارب المليون
مشاهده كان الفيديو بدون وهو عم يوقع على
كره القدم
[تصفيق]
صلاح الدين
اما الفيديو الثاني اللي حصل على اكثر من
مليون مشاهده فهو كمان لرونالدو و عم
بيوقع على الكره لكن هالمره اهداها بضربه
حظ لاحد الجماهير
[تصفيق]
واكيد كالعاده ما كانت عائله كريستيانو
رونالدو بعيده عن الاضواء ولا عن حفل
التقديم ولم تقل حفاوه استقبالهم عن حقائق
استقبال لاعب نادي النصر البرتغالي
رونالدو
جورجينا رودريجز كريستيانو
[تصفيق]
اللي اختار كلمه العالم الي يعرف عن هويته
الجديده وهي تسميه نادي النصر الي صار نجم
النجوم
[تصفيق]